ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BURNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI.
KANSEN CHU [inaudible]
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM.
DIAL THE DALY [inaudible]
DEEP. EIGHT MEN FLORA
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON.
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ AS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMóN OWN.
LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RAY IS THREE OF US US
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WEBER.
WICKS.
WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS --
SO WE MAY PROCEED.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN
THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A QUORUM
[inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
SO WE MAY PROCEED.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY
.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
WE ASK.
AT ARE GUESTS.
AND VISITORS.
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER
[inaudible]
THE TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
DALLY MISTER DALI [inaudible]
ALMIGHTY GOD.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO LIVE IN SUCH A WONDERFUL
STATE THAT YOU HAVE CREATED.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE ABUNDANCE
OF NATURAL RESOURCES.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE INNOVATION
AND CREATIVITY THAT THE PEOPLE
OF THIS STATE.
HAVE USED TO IMPACT THE WORLD.
FATHER YOU TEACHES IN MATTHEW
HOW TO PRAY.
OUR FATHER IN HEAVEN HALLOWED BE
YOUR NAME.
YOUR KINGDOM COME YOUR WILL BE
DONE ON EARTH AS IT IS IN HEAVEN.
WE ASK THAT HAVEN'T COME TO
EARTH.
FATHER WE HAVE EXPERIENCED.
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS.
YES THE YOU CONVERT THOSE WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR LOVED ONES THEIR
HOMES AND THEIR PROPERTY.
WE ASK THAT YOU HEAL OUR LAND.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE.
WE ASKED THE THAT YOU BLESS
EVERY LEGISLATOR IN THIS CAPITAL.
GIVE US WISDOM KNOWLEDGE
DISCERNMENT AND LOVE. TO HELP
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
FUTURE AND FUTURE GENERATIONS
THAT COME BEHIND US.
WE ASK THAT YOU BREAK THE CHAINS
OF ADDICTION.
THAT YOU HEAL THE MENTALLY ILL
FATHER GOD.
ANY YOU COMFORT THE HOMELESS.
PLEASE GIVE SPECIAL MAJOR OF
FAVOR FATHER GOD TO THE SPEAKER.
THE PRO TEM.
AND OUR GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM.
WE ASK THESE THINGS. FOR YOUR
GLORY IN YOUR HONOR OF YOUR
PURPOSES AND ACCORDING TO YOUR
WILL WE PRAY AMEN.
THANK YOU MISTER DALLI.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
REMAIN STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURGER* BATH AS SHE LEADS US
IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE READY BEGAN.
I PLEDGE. TO THE FLAG.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
AND HELLO.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY JANUARY THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT
NINE AM ON WILL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM THAT'S ON THE
PRESIDING CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK.
ASSISTING CLICK DAVID A BERMAN
READING THE ROLES CALLED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI MOVED A
QUORUM CALL THE ASSEMBLY MOTION
CARRIED TIME NINE OH THREE
ESTHER GLORIA MOVES AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS OF THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
EDUCATION TEMPTATIONS THERE ARE
NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE RECEIVED DURING THE JOINT
CONVENTION.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL.
IF YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY SILENCED
YOUR MOBILE PHONE PLEASE DO SO
NOW.
MEMBERS WE ARE PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MISTER GLORIA YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN EIGHT TO ALLOW SPEAKER
RENDON TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS.
ON THE FLOOR AT THE ROSTRUM AND
IN THE GALLERY FOR THE GOVERNOR
STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I REQUEST IS
GRANTED [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER.
NOW WE WILL RECESS REGULAR
SESSION AND CONVENE TO JAPAN
CONVENE THE JOINT SESSION.